so now Brady if you put those on your
camera if you look through a white light
source you're going to see a really
dramatic effect
today we're talking about why I can't
tell my rubbish bins apart when I go out
the night before to put them to the curb
you may be like me you have multiple
bins that are due to be put out on
different dates you have to keep track
of when the recycling goes out when the
normal rubbish goes out and here
knotting them we have several bins we
have to put out in my case one is green
one is black one is brown and often when
you go out at night you can't actually
tell them apart and that's because much
of the illumination that we get now from
street lights comes from a certain kind
of lamp called a sodium lamp that is
changing however certainly here not a.m.
around the country and probably in
places around the world there's a big
drive towards replacing those sodium
bulbs by LED light light-emitting diodes
which give a very different kind of
light so today we're going to talk about
why under sodium lamps we can't
distinguish colors very well this is a
light source that is emitting light at
only a single particular wavelength 589
nanometers and that corresponds to a
very yellow orange light as you can see
because that's the wavelength of yellow
in the optical spectrum so there's a
tube in here in which atoms of sodium
are being excited the electrons are
jumping up to high energy levels when
they fall down they emit a certain
wavelength of light corresponding to the
energy difference between those energy
levels well the question is why do we
see color at all if we're outside in the
daytime and our only source of
illumination is the Sun then the Sun we
know emits light at all wavelengths and
together that makes a very whitish light
doesn't emit light at exactly the same
amount at each wavelength but overall it
covers the whole spectrum however when
we have an artificial source of light
we're not always going to get that full
spectrum wavelength coverage and here's
a really extreme case of that so we
don't have white light at all we only
have one specific wavelength this very
very yellow light and so when we have
white light it may hit objects some of
that light will be absorbed some will be
transmitted and some will be reflected
it's only the light that's reflected
back to us that gives an object of color
so in the case of white
light all of those wavelengths are
provided and only some of them you know
bounce back to us if you don't have that
full spectrum to begin with if you're
only bouncing light of a certain color
off your object you're not going to be
able to distinguish what is true color
is so these are really fun these are
diffraction glasses and so each tin very
very fine fine much more fine than you
could actually see our little grooves
etched into the plastic and what happens
when the light passes through those is
its diffracted so it spreads out like a
prism will spread out white light and it
lets you see the whole rainbow of color
so Brady if you put the glasses over
your camera and you look at a white
light source you should see a pretty
spectacular effect with that white light
being spread out across all wavelengths
of the spectrum so now you're seeing
what is making up all that white light
but if you then look at our sodium lamp
you're not going to get that same effect
of course there isn't that wide
wavelength range to begin with to spread
out you should only see another image of
the same lamp because that's all you
have to diffract
so for comparison here's the white light
and then you can have a look at the
sodium lamp and see the difference okay
so let's go into the white light here so
here we have a fluorescent light
emitting wavelengths from the blue to
the red which gives it a white
appearance overall what do you go ahead
and so we've got our our our pana as
well yeah available the vending machine
right so we've got the full rainbow here
under the white light you know the the
white lights bouncing off the blue light
is bouncing off these ones so we see
them as blue the yellow lights bouncing
off these ones everything else is being
absorbed
however we take them back to our sodium
lamp we're going to see something very
different I'm following into the Bo C's
up now yeah I mean you can still tell
which ones are light and which ones are
dark but you've lost the hue you've lost
the ability to distinguish what color it
is what wavelength it is you can
probably take a pretty good educated
guess that that is yellow or orange
because it's matching the color of that
light
but beyond there I think you'd be
hard-pressed to determine which one is
blue green or purple so we've got some
crayons here but I don't think similarly
you would be able to tell apart which
ones these are do you want to be due to
become a camera woman yeah sure you hold
the camera oh it's you I'll put you out
of work this is your first time ever
yeah I'm behind the lens I want you to
take those crayons and write down what
you think what color you think each one
is using that crayon I mean I think
they're all brown but with a point right
brown for all of them I think that is
bright I think they're all brown that
might be orange that looks like a light
purple see I think that looks yellow to
red maybe okay there's the great
experiment Capulet what did I that's
about that okay so there's my there's my
guesses all right so we've got your
colors down here let's take it back into
the white light okay so you got the
yellow right but then again and thought
it was orange and then you got the green
right but I don't think you got anything
else right red was purple orange with
purple brown was red um I'm pleased I
got that one right
yeah well that's not surprising because
it's yellow light so imagine a city
where this is the only light source
available at night where these are what
the streetlights look like in reality
around here that's not quite the case
because these sodium lights we have our
high-pressure sodium right so while
they're intensely orange they're not
single wavelengths like this there's a
bit of mercury in the tube it gives it a
bit of coverage in the in the blue and
the violet but there are cities around
the world San Jose and California is one
of them that uses or has used low
pressure sodium lights completely to
illuminate the city
the reason San Jose did this is there's
actually an astronomical observatory
lick observatory on Mount Hamilton not
too far away so in the interests of
helping the astronomers maintain the
purity of the night sky they legislated
that they would use low pressure sodium
lights and so they produce a light
that's easily blocked out by filters for
the astronomers it makes everyday life
for every night life very challenging
you can't distinguish colors you can't
tell the colors of cars apart you pull
up to a curb that's painted red for no
parking you can't see it you get a
ticket from the observatory's point of
view if you've got a city that's nearby
and growing and encroaching and having a
lot of light pollution if you can keep
that light at a single wavelength then
it's better than nothing because you can
have a filter in place that would remove
only that amount of light if the light
is very broad spectrum very white
there's no filter that you can use to
remove all that so just with one filter
you can make the city almost visible
through the telescope well things are
changing now they're changing on a
household level I've changed all my
interior lights to LEDs because they're
energy-efficient they cost a little more
to put in but they're going to last for
10 or 15 years and they draw much much
less current so the running costs are
much lower the same thing is happening
on city and county wide levels so street
lights are being replaced with LEDs the
advantages are there's potentially
better ability to distinguish color you
get a you know more true representation
of color they are more energy efficient
so they cost less to run they're more
adaptable so you can dim them and you
can have the moment on switches they
don't take so long to light up and if
you get the casing right you can direct
the modal better as well but it's not
it's not a cut and dry case just because
one bulb is more energy efficient
doesn't mean your overall savings are
going to be greater if you go and put
lots more light bulbs out there some
people don't like the glare there's a
lot more reflection some of that
reflection may actually go up into the
night sky so it's not at all clear that
that's going to be better for light
pollution this is a transformation that
as we make this video is still very much
in progress and it's going to take some
adaptation on everyone's part to get
used to it what are you missing yeah I
like to be childlike do you have a
former spur or you're glad to see the
back of it I'm go out at night anymore
so actually from the from the space
station you can actually see changes in
cities as these transformations take
place you can see how city centers you
know the very color of them change it
as LED lights are put in
simply really emitted as heat and so by
the time they fall back to their ground
state they don't have as much energy to
get rid of and so the energy they emit
is lower energy than the energy they
absorbed